People always ask me why I'm sober
They think my life is boring or they think I'm missing out on life
that's not how I feel
life genuinely got better when I stopped drinking
and wasting my time
my energy, my money, on alcohol
and wasted conversations with people who
never gave me a genuine connection
conversation or overall substance in my life
So no, I'm not missing out on anything
Drinking isn't what life is about
Drinking isn't fun
Drinking will NEVER bring true happiness into anybody's life
Alcohol is literally poison
it's a depressant
The only thing I'm missing out on is a hangover
and am I really missing out?
I would say that
people are finally waking up and learning that drinking isn't what life is about
people are waking up and getting smart about their health
Which is honestly a good thing
Instead of letting society tell them drinking every weekend
or partying is normal,
adds value to your life?
because it truly doesn't